i am done i am done i am done someone
booked my
flight home i'm just like
heartbroken katie thurston's season of
the bachelorette is going to be
full of all kinds of drama that's
something to find out
a sneak peek of what's to come on
katie's journey to love
promises tears heartbreak and romance
the clip kicks off with lots of
shirtless men on a cowboy themed
date then katie's adventure and
romance-filled dates takes center stage
with her sex positivity
on full display she's beautiful she's
funny
she's sex positive are you naked i can
come back another time
can someone just tell me when fantasy
suites are please leading up to the
season premiere
katie opened up to e.t about being open
and honest when it comes to s-e-x
but i like the fact that a lot of those
guys too said we love her because she is
sex positive we love her because she is
free
like that and it makes us feel
comfortable to be who we are i'm
embracing who i am and if the guy can't
accept
you know me being sex positive or
talking about sex it's just not going to
work out
there are some people who are a little
traditional in old school but you know
but people around my age and younger
like we're here for is 2021 embrace your
sexuality and be
empowered woman the preview also shows
several of the men expressing their
feelings for the 30 year old bank
marketing manager
and here's what kd tells some of the
other guys
you make me happy every day when we're
together
wow it's magic i love you
but those three little words should come
as no surprise
katie told e.t she falls in love more
than once throughout the course of her
season
do you have a happy ending everything
happens for a reason and when you
embrace that and that you let go of
control
then you find your happiness as for the
drama this season it all hits the fan
when blake moynes arrives late
something that shocks katie and gets the
men all riled up
i am a little bit late to this but katie
is the one
so i just had to show up you need to get
the [ __ ] out of my way
blake appeared on claire crawley and
tasha adams shared season of the show
and katie told et
that it was a little awkward to have him
show up
since tasha is one of the show's hosts
this season
alongside caitlyn bristow the way tasha
handled blake is something
that's very uh involved so you'll just
have to see kind of how that pans out
she got to talk to blake first and the
tears flow when mike
a 31 year old gym owner addresses his
virgin
status i didn't think it would come this
quick sex is not something i take
lightly
but katie had nothing but nice things to
say about mike to e.t
someone who surprised me you guys will
have to see how that relationship
develops i mean it gets intense
and speaking of intense one man admits
he came on the show for followers
an ambulance arrives and everyone cries
a lot i came here to all love
do i continue here or do i just
leave now i am done i am done i am done
someone booked my flight home katie
opened up to et about the moment she
almost called it quits so there's a
moment where i
am ready to call it quit and uh i'll
just say you know this this journey
journey's not easy
and if it wasn't for tasha and caitlyn
and some other people that you guys will
find out about
i don't know that i could have done it
so does katie get her happily ever after
here's what she teased to e.t okay let
me see that left hand
i'm looking for a tan line
are you engaged i'm engaged to myself
that's what i've been saying for now